i am
so excited that when i reached out to
priyanka
she did not say i'm busy
after canada's drag race my life
exploded
like truly exploded oh and one more
thing
what's my name
i can't believe my life i'm a pop star
now
you are a pop star congrats on your ep
how are you feeling achieving a dream
like this
it's so iconic because i'm just such a
product of all my hard work so to see
another
another one another
another accolade you know i'm trying to
be a cane icon like shania twain today
so i think it's working you wanna pick
up this cake
i'm feeling so hot i'm the chocolate
baby come on take that shot
the other thing with drag queen music is
everyone thinks it's going to be bad
always free i'm not going to lie to you
because that's just not who i
am these tracks are so damn good
music is whatever you want it to be and
music is truly like the universal
language that we all can speak
you are in the drag race world all-star
six is airing right now so good
who do you think has what it takes to
snatch the crown
i'm honestly like super
super impressed with trinity k bonnet
it's just nice to see somebody
that obviously wasn't the most
celebrated on their season of drag race
come back and just remind us that
they're coming on through coming on
through coming for you